Good morning, John. So, I am headed off to
Miami tomorrow morning at six o'-freakin'-clock
in the morning. I will be there in Miami;
I will do a show first. There's only 50 tickets
left and we're not selling 'em at the door,
so you have to buy them online in the next
24 hours or you're done.
And then, the morning after that concert I
will be getting up at... really early — like,
4:00 my time — to go to Haiti. Which reminds
me, because it is now two days before my trip,
I need to go take my malaria medication.
[package snaps open]
Hopefully this will not cause, uh, dizziness
or nausea or hallucinations like they say
they could, 'cause that would suck.
I got these things at the "travel doctor,"
and she said to me, "I have good news: the
malaria that they have in Haiti is — is
the killer strain."
And of course, I'm like, "I agree with you
that that is... news."
But apparently that is a good thing, because
the kind of malaria that kills you is also
the kind of malaria that these always work
against. So that's good.
So John, a long, long time ago, you and I
went to the Dominican Republic, and we took
a tour with a microfinance organization. And
you can watch that video; it's deep in the
archives of Brotherhood 2.0. I will link to
it at the end of this video.
But the thing about it is that the Dominican
Republic is, like, ten times better off than
Haiti. But this is strange, because Haiti
and the Dominican Republic are on the same
small island, Hispaniola.
People do, of course, have opinions, thoughts,
ideas about this. There are three schools
of thought.
First, I'm gonna tell you about the one that
is probably the least, uh, obvious... and
that's the environment. So let's pretend like
this camera battery is Hispaniola.
So one-third of it would be Haiti, this third
over here; and the rest of it would be the
Dominican Republic. And then right here, on
the border of the two, is a giant mountain
range.
All of the warm, wet air hits, and it lands
in the Dominican Republic, and then it all
falls before it gets to the top of the mountains.
So it falls in the mountains and then it rolls
right back down off the edge of the D.R. So
what we have is a wet side and a dry side.
And water is a very important ingredient for
making most things... particularly for agriculture;
also for other industries.
This was all exacerbated by the second thing,
which was colonialism. Haiti was pretty much
France's biggest investment in the Western
Hemisphere. They really pushed it. Whereas
the Dominican Republic had about 20,000 slaves,
Haiti — a third the size with less water
— had 300,000.
The Dominican Republic was... was owned by
Spain, by the way.
The agricultural policies that they put in
place were really exploitative, ended in a
lot of deforestation, which of course ends
in more runoff, less soil, and less water
retention — all bad things for agriculture.
Haiti shucked its colonialism a lot sooner
than most of the rest of the world. And while
there was, for some time, stability in Haiti,
the story of Haiti in the 20th century is
one of the third problem: Really, really bad
government.
Military coups, civil war, war with the Dominican
Republic, military occupation by the United
States, dictators, military rule — every
bad government situation that you could think
of.
The longest period of stability was under
the Duvaliers, uh, first François and then
his son, Jean-Claude who were, as Shakespeare
would say, gigantic partially-digested lumps.
Aside from their military forces killing people
for political reasons, raping people for fun;
they, themselves, uh, took foreign aid and,
uh, all tax money and put it in their pockets.
The Duvalier reign finally ended in 1986 for
the same reason that all tyrannical dictatorships
end: the people got too hungry.
Since 1986 when the Duvalier reign ended,
there have been attempts at democracy, followed
by more military coups. And at this point,
Haiti is still trying to figure out its democratic
process and, of course, as you would expect,
the people of Haiti have very little faith
in that process.
It is not a good situation, and I dare you
to come up with a solution, because no one
can. But that, of course, does not mean that
we can't help people, at least in small ways.
And I'm excited to be a part of that and hopefully
allow you, uh, to help as well in the future.
John, I'll see you on Wednesday... except
that I won't. Because there's no Internet
in Haiti. So I'll see you whenever I get back
to the Internet. Goodbye.
I won't have time to make a video on Friday,
so I filmed one yesterday. It's about superhero
superpowers. And John, I'm gonna need you
to upload that video because clearly, not
a lot of Internet in Haiti.